los niños deberían sentirse seguros en
la escuela pero en algunas partes de
nigeria los centros de enseñanza se han
convertido en un target para los grupos
armados y los secuestros son cada vez
más constantes este viernes al menos 300
estudiantes fueron secuestrados de un
instituto femenino del gobierno en el
estado de zamfara en el noroeste del
país
hombres armados allanaron el colegio
mientras las jóvenes dormían las
autoridades encontraron a unas 50
escolares que lograron escapar de sus
captores el secuestro de niñas en la
escuela secundaria del gobierno deja
nieve es una grave violación del derecho
internacional humanitario y socava el
derecho a la educación de miles de niños
en el norte de nigeria este es el
segundo secuestro masivo de estudiantes
en nigeria en poco más de una semana
luego de que el pasado 17 de febrero
hombres armados raptaron a 42 personas
en el estado de níger todavía en
cautividad en diciembre de 2020 344
alumnos fueron secuestrados en cáscara y
liberados días después tras una
negociación monetaria entre los
secuestradores y el gobierno muchos
nigerianos critican la falta de
estrategia gubernamental para proteger a
los estudiantes de los bandidos que
operan por dinero y para liberar
miembros de la cárcel y es que el
derecho a la educación de los jóvenes
nigerianos está en alto riesgo
especialmente en las regiones rurales
más vulnerables que nunca
y la implicación de estos secuestros
generalizados es que más padres tendrán
que sacar a sus hijos de las escuelas ya
que el estado ya no puede evitar que
ocurran estos secuestros con terroristas
devastadores esto es realmente triste
para nigeria
la nación de áfrica occidental es
testigo de este tipo de ataques que
saltaron al panorama internacional en
2014 cuando los yihadistas de boko haram
secuestraron a 276 niñas en su boca más
de un centenar siguen desaparecidas
mientras las organizaciones humanitarias
exigen al gobierno una acción enérgica
para mantener y garantizar una educación
segura
[Música]